how's it going guys uh greg and john here
today and we are going to talk about uh this
i think this is the third week my god i've
lost count it's been going on for so long
of the johnny depp amber heard trial amber
heard had a couple days of testimony and here's
my thought process on this was we originally
i just wanted to do like a podcast
because have like a real discussion it's like
the back and forth that john and i have when
talking about this because i've listened if if i
haven't listened to all i've at least listened to
the vast majority of this trial and uh definitely
all of amber hurt's testimony as the most recent
part of it and uh we have a podcast that
i was like we could just upload it to that
and so if there's then we have a
video recording going on right now so
if there's no video there's no video there's
a video it's up we i decided okay you know
what fine screw it let's just throw it up
there uh because yeah and they go i know
like here's here's the truth i i i i personally
and i consume this trial way more than john does i
i personally could do a video about this every day
like if i really wanted to milk the most popular
subject right now in entertainment media uh yeah
i easily could because i i i'm so up to date
with it and it's something i talk about people
all the time and this would be like the third
thing second thing was not even like a real
i was just like that dub of uh jason momoa
yeah the second real discussion about it you did
that one editorial piece yeah and this the thing
is though is like i i i'll hear other videos and
such and um it seems like you kind of have to be
one-sided especially if you're doing youtube
videos it's pretty much you got to be like
a hundred percent all in johnny depp you know
that's how all debates work and no no no gray
area whatsoever i i know right now even saying
that that just that turns people off right away
and i do have my opinions about a a lot more than
than just justice for johnny or something like
that and so i'm just hoping that this can be more
of a an open discussion and really just talking
the way how we talk when there isn't a camera
rolling and we're not worried about presentation
or watch time comments yeah yeah like really
just like try to be honest which is kind of the
challenge of theirs on a much bigger global scale
of be honest in front of a room full of people and
and and then knowing this is being broadcasted to
the world and everyone's having everyone's playing
jury right now so yeah following up on everything
where to kick it off i guess i'm there's a bit
like questions like is is amber heard telling the
truth or not is she telling the truth and i don't
know it's probably more complicated than yes or no
right this whole thing seems more complicated than
a simple yes or no yeah it's like there's a lot
of evidence to go against her that they've managed
to get physical evidence of like audio recordings
and just testimonials of people countless messages
yeah yeah some real emotional testimonials
too to go against her and i'll i'll say this
i do have a hard time believing her i do i
have a very difficult time believing her when i
watch her testify i have a lot of the same
thoughts that i think a lot of other people do
and i i weirdly don't go on twitter or
scroll through the comments because i try to
first figure out how i'm feeling before i let
myself be influenced by another thought and then
sometimes then afterwards i'll probably i'll go
on and i'll see how people are thinking and i'm
like yeah that is that is sort of where my head's
at too and it is something i try to figure out
you know it's like one of the first things is i i
don't really watch the trial i mainly listen but
when i would listen to amber heard and especially
during a lot of like the the deep size and the
the this like this i the way i describe it is
it feels very theatrical like it's it sounds
like uh it's almost a narration something about
it would ring false to me that i would i found
myself watching her instead of simply listening to
her and like a lot of people like one of the most
joked about things is something that i definitely
was thinking was the crying that she does
seems fake because when someone cries there's more
than just tears hey she doesn't have any tears
so that's like sign number one to me that this
this seems fake um the other part is like there's
other signs of you know your cheeks can turn red
there can be snot there there's there's cracking
in the voice like real cracking that happens your
eyes turn red you know there's a there's a lot of
that that doesn't really seem like like real
tears and i'm not gonna be the kind of person
who would say a person who has suffered domestic
violence wouldn't recount a story like that
because everyone deals with dv differently
everyone handles it differently and everyone
is at a different stage in their life when it
comes to dv a lot of people haven't gotten over
it a lot of people have been able to put it behind
them and a lot of people have gone to therapy a
lot happened so everyone has like a different
way of recounting it i would love to go into
my life i choose not to um only because
i'm aware of the connection it has to
other people that are still in my
life and i wouldn't want to then
inadvertently put parts of their life out there
does that does that make sense yeah no i don't
want to it it by you know by association it it
it involves them yeah it's not only your story
yeah yeah and so that's that's a big part of why
i choose no that's a choice i made like um before
even we were doing youtube like that was something
i learned from facebook of putting stuff out there
and i decided just you know i'm just not gonna
do that and um so i do take the subject really
serious you know some some criticisms about
amber heard i i do i don't fully agree with
of like the this person wouldn't do that i'm
like well you know i've i i have been around
people like when you i've had to tell my story
to people and i will talk to you know if i don't
really know the person i can look them in the
eyes i can talk to them i mean it's a little
something you told me that is so true though
is like 99 of us don't know what it's like
and again you know that's what i
mean it's so it's it's so easy for
if you are someone who has suffered from it
especially a woman to put your experience
onto how she's describing it and then go
i don't i didn't do i wouldn't do that
and i and i know other people who wouldn't do
that so i i'm i believe she's false same time
there's the flip side yeah everybody behaves
differently yeah same time there's the flip
side though where people would people who have
suffered the stories that she is recounting
might automatically believe her simply
because of the fact that it it's there's this
identification this catharsis
this feeling of bravery of
because i do believe full-heartedly that there are
so many women like countless women who have been
who have suffered domestic violence who
have suffered sexual assault who then
don't get a day in court don't get don't get a
voice or immediately shut down anything there's
no retribution there's nothing and it's just
damage that they then have to move forward with
and that falls on then it becomes only their
responsibility to deal with that and that's a
lonely harsh struggle i see yeah and friends
of mine even to today who have been through
some things that have never received any kind of
retribution and and less too just broad support
and it's it's really hard to watch and it can
be very high it can be very isolating for people
so yeah that's what i mean like both sides
seem possible like one way to look at it is
this is why i think she's lying and another
way to look at it is like this is why she's
telling the truth because why why would she do
this well yeah yeah and i mean you know there
are all sorts of conspiracy theories you can have
and i i do believe that yeah there's some people
out there who are sociopathic and who do connive
but i have trouble figuring out if that's really
what's happening here because yeah i look at
the situation i go okay even if she was in this
to get some big divorce settlement or something or
to take advantage of a cultural wave it seems like
you're talking about like the beginning like
when when she first went got the restraining
order or it got publicized and then the op-ed
piece the beginning and the perpetuation too
even because now this has become such a spiral
of time pain and money and she's counter-suit
like johnny depp is counter-suing her currently
and then she's going to counter sue him again and
that suggests to me that at least either these
two parties really believe in their stories
or she if she is a sociopath has just dug the
hole so deep that she can't climb out now and i
find that like the last resort of thinking i guess
is the sort of cartoon villainy of like i'm going
to be a sociopath wreck your career get your money
and skate away as some kind of social justice icon
it it seems like this is a bad way to achieve that
to me i mean yeah because i mean at this point
i look at the situation i'm like what is anyone
gaining from this and i mean johnny depp certainly
seems to be gaining in the public eye but even
the things that they have put into evidence
don't really shine a flattering light on either
of them and they contribute to me more of that
gray area i mean as it appears especially after
in light of that one particular tape they often
replay of her going like okay i didn't slap you
this way i hit you and you know defining the ways
in which you know uh you can be hit and and what
his response should or shouldn't be and belittling
it like there are certain aspects of her you know
behavior on record that do seem abusive and do
seem like they could be outside just the genuine
sort of i don't know what to do in this situation
um but at the same time you know there's a
whole bunch of gray area especially involving
drugs that i think just makes this whole situation
really hard for me to get a clear read on because
while i'm like yeah i don't think johnny depp is
necessarily the monster as they keep coming back
to that motif of the monster i believe the monster
is based on something real though and is probably
in there to some degree and i mean you look at the
way he talks about her and i'm like yeah i mean
there's some malice there so it's one of those
things where i don't think this is just a false
situation that she is contributed just to get
money i guess is is is the one conclusion i can
solidly maybe get close to that's it well
that's the thing is like there's more to come
there's there's more to come too and like
i said we're all playing jury that's where
this all keeps coming back to i mean you guys
talking about like let's let's talk about the
the johnny depp side of things because the flip
side too also is why would johnny depp go through
all this if he really did do this you know because
a lot of the time like maybe he just had enough
evidence to kind of put her to shame whatever
like if i'm playing devil's advocate on on certain
things because i i like it's hollywood and there's
so many entertainment in music and movies and
granted it's a different time because the metoo
movement and such people taking more serious at
the same time a lot of people get away with [__]
all the time you know and i really do think like
yeah this would have followed him this this would
have followed him but he was already on a rebound
in a lot of ways if he just stuck true to his
career you know like it seems like he really
cared at least that's the way it it perceived to
me because he was still doing movies he did get
grindelwald you know like he did have films coming
he got like pirates five still came out and didn't
make a billion dollars but it still made a lot of
money and it's like there was enough this is the
most his truth has been out there this is the
like all these things that are being headlined
and clipped out and actually making the news
that's been out there for years and and it's
only now because of the trial that it's in the
mainstream media so that helps them out because
i think at least in the court of public opinion
he's definitely won so many more people over
what were you talking about or there was something
you said you said a lot of thoughts and so there's
trying to turn to that thing where i was making
a lot of mental notes and i was like oh no lost
lost most of them yeah johnny depp in the court
of public opinion generally no no no there's
something else about her i'm not sure like i
i was literally sitting watching the testimony
of her and going why why don't i really believe
her and i think there's another there are things
i'm questionable about for sure like especially
with something that is not in the trial but is
uh was making its way on social media but i
guess it might count as hearsay or some [__]
objection is um her you see you're talking
about like johnny depp's stories and they're
both painting each other not in the greatest
light like yeah johnny depp when he testifies
he has stories that go in there that don't paint
him in the greatest light but then when i hear the
someone say but however however when i hear
the like the audio recordings and such it still
sounds like this is the same guy who's testifying
do you know what i mean yeah even even at the the
even when you get him like saying something
horrible it still sounds like no this lines
up with the same guy doesn't seem like he's
painting a false image he doesn't feel like
he's orchestrating yeah yeah the the skeptic
in me will go join up is an amazing actor
that's where the skeptic of me
comes out right yeah maybe he just
really knows what he's doing and uh based my
testimony on keith richards no it seems it seems
really consistent and he has a big reputation of
for being a certain type of individual to others
so it lines up still even with the stuff that
doesn't paint him as well in a good life that
came out during when it was really his time with
his witnesses and such whereas with amber heard
um it she really paints herself
as like super duper innocent like
so innocent not the aggressor she's she's
like such a victim and he was this monstrosity
like it like it's just it's such the antithesis
it's such a wild antithesis to there's like no
gray area with her you know yeah and her and the
story she's telling that i'm like this doesn't
at all like this just seems to contradict so
much of the uh the testimonials we've heard
the audios we've heard all these things
and the other part of me does go to
like with with the we will talk about some other
stuff but the when it comes to the the acts of
violence of like these just sheer like it's insane
what she is describing just insane what she this
this terrific it's horrific and there are people
who really suffer that and worse and sometimes
leads to death these are real things that she
is describing like terrible terrible things
and and and apar like if she's telling the truth
and good on her you know she's telling the truth
and good the part of me that makes me doubtful
is when when i'm like how come there's like she
she clearly would take videos and photos of him
like she passed out he's got a little bit of a
temper tantrum right now uh we're again we're in
an argument let me record this as a way to have
something on him to expose him in case and and it
made me go well why why don't you have like any
photos of this sometimes when she's describing
incidents like a big part of this whole ordeal
is you know the the photos that did become famous
where she when she got the restraining order and
she was all bruised and then she like went on a
talk show i think it was cordon like the next day
and after that the day of that supposed beating
and then she she was fine like like no one saw
anything on her like a lot went to go that
was fake what she did that was there's so
much to support that that was fake so when
she's describing this this guy you know it's
it it makes me questionable of how come
there's not like when we're talking about
domestic violence or sexual assault it's it's
so hard the reason why it's so hard for women
especially in is because it's it's so hard to
like get the perfect crime that is documented
and videotaped and recorded in order to prove
your point you know it's it's really it's so
it's so hard so that's the thing that she can
lean on that's why i'm bringing up all these other
things that she documented so how come and and the
thing is so much of this so volatile and emotional
that i'm talking about kind of a logical way
of thinking when a lot of the time in toxic
relationships logic is thrown out of the window
like logically they should have broken up a
long time ago toxicity is there to mask the
logic yeah yeah and you know you hear about
the the way they started their relationship
like they the both of their testimonies line up
of they were both coming off of the heels like
johnny depp was still with his girlfriend and
according to his testimony and you know she
would think was in the middle of a divorce
or separation something of that nature
so they're both coming off the heels
and ideally when you're in a relationship that's
ending you want to be single for a while so you
can heal and grieve from that from such a
commitment of that life partner that you had
and and then go into relationships so when you
have that toxic whatever whatever negativity has
brewed up in you with that relationship
ideally you want to get over that first
so you don't bring it into your next relationship
yeah you know and it sounds like this was destined
from the get-go to be something that was
oftentimes we people mistake toxicity for passion
and some people think you need those fights yeah
to to keep you guys in a gravitational pull or
something like that and yeah you have a situation
that began out of i'm going to assume some level
of trauma you know two relationships dissolving
a new one coming out of that dissolution but
also between two people with as this trial is well
established a lot of history of abuse in childhood
in their younger lives and i definitely believe
that those things can harmonize later on and can
bring something you know out of people and yeah
i mean to go back to what to what you said like
that's the main like i guess i sympathize in a way
i hesitate to to pick one team because the quote
always comes back to me that there are three sides
to any story there's mine yours and the truth
and i feel like the truth always has to be
somewhere in between and yeah the big thing
about amber heard to me is that there are aspects
of what she's willing to give up that don't seem
to ring as true as what johnny's willing to give
up it seems like his testimony he was pretty much
they constantly asked him if they're reading his
words correctly half those words are pretty uh you
know unpleasant and he's always just like yeah
yeah you did so there is a certain willingness
i think to accept some of that behavior but the
problem is the digger i the deeper i dig the more
i'm like well that could be a tactic you know you
admit to some smaller things so that you can deny
the bigger thing or you know there's so many gray
areas to play at and to look at and yeah i i think
ultimately the problem for me in just going
johnny that must be right is the fact that
for a lot of these situations he is allegedly
on many a substance and i just believe that
things happen when you're unaware of yourself
so i can't fully discredit the idea that amber
heard could be telling the truth and i
know that it's really hard for people
in her position which is what worries me the most
because if she is truly being fraudulent in these
claims and as being the sociopath the court of
public opinion has has deemed her that's bad like
that's bad for the future that's bad for like
that could set a precedent that could set the
whole movement and i know the metoo movement is
very contentious for people and a lot of people
don't really like it uh and i feel like something
like this could easily set the progress made by
something like that back really heavily or call
further into doubt like i get what people struggle
with in the argument of like we believe all women
immediately but at the same time to me it's sort
of like there better be some really extreme
circumstances as to how these falsehoods were
contrived basically because again it just
seems to my moral compass it's about the
the most vile thing you can do to fabricate
something like this and then to draw it out
into this kind of circus so a party even
like amber heard's ex-assistant came out
talking about how uh amber heard this is
before the trial stole her sexual assault story
i mean if that's true that's disgusting that's
absolutely disgusting because the problem is
that it's really hard for a lot of women out
there i don't speak from experience but i
have seen the experiences of just friends alone
no that's what's so angering that's that's what's
angry about it if it is indeed if she is not
telling the truth it's just that's the part of
i think the thing is is that the thing like you
do got to take a side that i'm not saying you
have to i'm saying like that's that's how the
the public on like social media makes you one
feel yeah like you have to take a side you know
because in this court case like with johnny depp
even if it was reactionary abuse right even if
it was reactionary if he did indeed like fight
back in any way or hit back it's that data was
gonna that could take him down in this specific
legal case a lot of people will defend him that
in this legal case that's bad news for johnny depp
i could that could really result in him losing
so the the part of it that i think johnny
depp owns up to is like being at times emotionally
abused i don't know if he's actually declared it
but it's he's you know talked about being like
emotionally and verbally abusive they're even if
it is reaction even if it is reactionary abuse it
still is in that category yeah it's demonstrably
evident by the the videos and the tapes that they
show like yeah there's definitely toxicity and
abuse in these rooms with these two sides yeah
where where i'm not i'm not trying to see like
to give there's this one part that really casts
a lot of doubt when it came to for me in terms of
the johnny depp side uh there was this like text
message that uh let me see if i could find it
really quick i'll just i'll just read it because
um i think it is important and i don't think it
might be brought up in the trial um i i haven't
seen it brought up in the trial yet but i i do
think it's an important thing to bring up where
she was talking with here it is i've found it
it's been going around online uh johnny depp's
ex-assistant stephen uh deuters to amber hurt
where amber told the story on on in the testimony
recently about getting kicked by johnny depp when
he was drugged up and stephen said i think he's
just texted you he's incredibly apologetic and
know that he has done wrong he wants to get
better now he's been very explicit about that
this morning feels like we're at a critical
juncture she says yes but i don't know how to
be around him after what he did to me yesterday
i don't know if i can stay with him these are
private text messages he wants and steven says
he wants to see you so much he's distraught
amber says don't worry about the flights i'll
be taking care of them myself thank you look
he thinks he doesn't deserve this obviously
he has no idea what he did or to the extent
that he did it if someone was truly honest with
him about how bad it really was he'd be appalled
the man and definitely wouldn't say to
me that he doesn't deserve it i'm sad
he doesn't have a better way to really
know the severity of his actions
yesterday unfortunately for me i remember
in full detail everything that happened and
this is the kicker no pun intended bad terrible
choice of words terrible choices unintentionally
um he was this is steven says he was appalled
when i told him he kicked you he cried
it was disgusting and he knows it i wasn't with
him this is where it's cut off though oh like
i wasn't with him when he and then it's cut off
so i don't know what the rest of that sentence is
when he apologized and made everything right
again or i wasn't with him when when he did it
or something you know um but this is like way
before any of this other stuff was like really
coming out this is like still when they were like
no let's make this relationship work yeah yeah
well yeah i mean and to think too i mean there's
the evidence of this case alone but i remember
you way back like sort of absorbing and being sent
even more you know stuff in the past yeah and yeah
i mean it's a moment like that like that's
a pretty interesting thing to me and that's
again the the the major gray area for me with
johnny depp is like generally just the way it
strikes me the way people's accounts go yeah it
seems like he is a sweet genuine probably very
caring guy when he's aware i know people that
know him and and i also am very cautious of
my bias that i could have simply because i love
the actor johnny depp i loved it yeah and i
oh even when i thought even before all this
happened and i thought his his career was going
weird in town i was always rudin and it would
always watch the trailer if he was in it you
know i was always curiou i'm always curious to see
what he's doing like i'm always fascinated by him
he's the star of my very favorite movie yeah
several of my other favorite movies yeah he's
he is a talent that i've always admired
and i've loved watching interviews with him
you know and i've wanted to be like you know
yeah yeah he's that kind of dude that you would
see you're just like he just seems so cool guys
like him women like him and he doesn't seem like
an ego maniacal dude he just seems like he really
doesn't give a [__] and he's like cool and calm
you know yeah absolutely and and and has these fun
idiosyncrasies that i just admire you know and i
there's this story and not to make things much
much worse but every great story starts that way
that it's not being brought up because i believe
here's what i'll say i full-heartedly believe
johnny depp is telling his version of the truth
that's how it appears even in these text messages
right that i just read yeah he's there's nothing
of the the account is he doesn't if he did it he
certainly doesn't remember it and when
being told he did it he broke down crying
mm-hmm you know it feels like it tracks it
feels more like if he did do something he wasn't
full he wasn't um he did it uh [__] and how was
the [__] word he was inebriated yeah he was a
nebri yeah yeah he wasn't in control or aware of
his full faculties yeah like if he if he did do it
but um that's how it strikes i mean that would be
absolutely diabolical if it were to come out that
you know this is all an act on his side yeah i
mean from from him i mean it's still abuse but
it certainly seems as though the the danger
with johnny depp is more is he hopped up is
he coping you know talks with toxic substances and
whatnot and is that leading to these retaliations
and these uh uh outbursts these these lashings
out so to speak yeah like i remember years ago
there was this he told the story on inside
the actor's studio with james lipton i'm not
finding it there's like a two-minute it's like a
two-minute thing that he was talking about about
being bullied specifically being bullied and his
mother who obviously played a big influence into
his development like anyone anyone who's around
their mom growing up if they would but in terms
of his trauma of you know explanation as to why
he would be attracted to such a relationship
uh his mother played a big part and he used to
paint he wouldn't talk about this side of his
mother until this trial and all this [__] versus
uh on inside the actor's studio he was telling a
story about being bullied and if i remember
correctly you could probably find it and you
could correct me if i get any of this wrong if
i remember correctly the story he was telling
was that if they start bullying you take the
rock and either threaten them or hit them with it
and then he said after he did one of those i'm
not going to say which one he did because i
simply don't remember if he just threatened
with it or actually hit them i don't remember
um but he said he did that and they never
bothered him again so he's learned to like
that's how he deals with bullies granted this
interview was years ago he's in his 50s about
time he married amber people people grow and like
i feel like i'm a different person every two to
three years i might look back on this conversation
in two to three years maybe even a week from
nowhere and then depending on how this all goes
and and and be like oh man you know i actually
think very differently than i did then not just
about the subject just about life in general
and so you know to take something someone said
like 20 years ago and apply it you know that's
why i think a lot of it's like silly to to bring
up you know like in 1998 you did this you know
yeah like he's probably a completely different
person yeah it's like you can draw something
from that but also i feel like the passage
of time needs the credit that it's due
at the same time this this uh sentiment that like
he didn't abuse these other people so why would he
do this now and i'm like fair true if he didn't
that he didn't harm them um same time there's a
different relationship that was then yeah this
is a different relationship coming off of one
that was ending badly and clearly with someone
who i do for i do believe was the main main one
to provoke the main aggressor the main initiator
amber who they they have audio of them directly
of if of him saying like you start physical fights
you start these fights and she's like yeah i start
these fights because you're you won't engage with
me unless i hate you you know like so that's just
like it's pretty much an admission of guilt on
theirs that she is the aggressor she's the star so
you know that that's why i think a lot of people
believe that many that where johnny depp comes
from is reactionary abuse that's why i keep
saying that word because he's not he would
he wouldn't just instigate this or start
this you know and she seems easily provoked
yeah and she's got abandonment issues
man like i get it i i get i understand
the like it's it's i'm saying is i understand
not that i i don't sympathize with the choice and
actions i don't want that to be misconstrued i
do understand abandonment issues very well though
and to um have a histrionic personality
disorder i'm not that well versed in it
but see there's the other i don't like zip
zagging around here but that's the other part
was that the dr curry person who who testified
talked about how she i think she was saying she
believed amber heard has histrionic personality
disorder and a lot of the symptoms of why she
said that is shown during her testimony
like a lot of the things that she described
are are are there and i wasn't even
thinking about that on the surface
it would some someone did i saw on this was
a thing i did see on social media of someone
clipped out the part where she because i listened
to a testimony and i kind of forgot about all that
because there's i'm just absorbing this whole
thing and then i and then and i listened to it
again and then i continued watching the amber
her testimony i'm like yeah this is all there
so i forgot my the original thing i was talking
about before the historic personality disorder
well in abandonment issues and abandonment
like a lot of things that like fallen off
onto this category that the actions of that
that are described of this individual that
are caught on on recordings and such do
seem that way of someone who does suffer
from from this damage and then when i watch
like a testimony and it doesn't ring sincere
but you were saying something that i'm like that's
all that that could potentially be a fair point of
she must be aware that the the public is not
in her favor so she might be working extra
hard to sell the story yeah and the burden of this
particular trial is basically on her to prove that
her account is correct beyond a shadow of a doubt
and so like she might be telling the truth but she
might be playing up the emotions and being more
animated yeah i mean i don't know you know and
like i really need to cry yeah like i don't know
how law show to take this but yeah i mean it's
got to be really strange and uncomfortable for any
person to do what is essentially a big open public
therapy session yeah uh where you you know you
tear open all the wounds and i mean i know they're
that we're where this ver where it depends on a
few people strangers determining whether or not
you are telling you are sincere yeah or
whether you're being truthful yeah and whether
the abuse that at least you have experienced
yourself or that you you know feel is part of
your reason for being here you know is either
legitimized or delegitimized based on you know
those decisions and what those people have to say
and so as much as there are body language experts
out there i've seen just as many videos in my
life about body language experts just nailing
people and then the flip side where people go yes
but there are like so many things that influence
you could have kept talking oh sorry yeah i just
didn't want you to miss a minute um but yeah
like there's so many factors that contribute to
body language and yeah like they certainly could
be indicative of her being disingenuous
on the stand but i feel like especially
she to me she is the loneliest person
in that room no matter what because
she has to defend this really horrific account
which if it's true has to be emotionally
difficult to say the least and if it's not
true it's got to be just as difficult in a
totally other way that requires way more mental
spiritual awful coordination well i mean you have
they have these videos of like what it's like when
johnny depp shows up to court and fans are like
yippee johnny i love you justice and then
amber shows up and it's not welcoming
you know roll out the carpet for her you know yeah
it's not like there's a team amber that's just as
vocal and then people who want to like attend
the trial a lot of them in the background who
are sitting there i i i don't know but they kind
of read like some of them are johnny depp fans
well and they've had to to calm them down
or else kick them out yeah yeah yeah the
judges had to say that well i think does a
pretty good job that the judge is trying to
keep this even and moving along as best as she can
yeah well yeah it's because like i you know if i
even though i have a really hard time like buying
the sincerity of amber heard's testimony because
and i did i did write like i listened to the the
clip and i put down things that stood out to me
that the dr curry said of like overly
dramatic presentation it's like the way she
recounts stories sound like a like a someone
put it to me like a romance novel yeah
lots of embellishments yeah impressionistic
speech very flowery feels like it often lacks
any substance a big part is quick shift between
emotions like she'll do the face that like really
like the crying face like trying to cry and
then and then she could just switch out of it
like it's it's bizarre it's it is
bizarre it's just like this like
like it's not even like a recovery you
know of it it's it's like a whoa like
it's like someone yelled cut yeah and then i guess
someone's like or something you know yeah yeah so
then are we to believe that those are decisions
or are those just how she express i don't know
it's like i've met people who who in just regular
life who kind of meet that criteria the pain in
the audio tapes not when they're like i didn't
hit you johnny but like the p when she is
divulging pain again you know it's like look
i don't think she's a talented of an actress
and it's when she's you know it's like it is
the thing of all these we're trying to factor
in like all the of the possible different
circumstances if we are to obviously i i
pretty much have an opinion on her and uh and
i i i go okay let me assume now that she's
telling the truth of why i might have a hard time
believing her if she is telling the truth yeah um
i do want to get into that bottle story
i i do i do i do want to because that's
like that's the one i'm i am the most like
trepidicious to touch uh at the same time
there are things i've heard on
both sides and i'm like well
let me talk about that but what was i just talking
about i keep forgetting my my train of thought
we're talking about her personality traits and
the way she portrays emotions and things like that
and her investigating things in the table
oh yeah oh yeah the tape she sounds sincere
but that's a different environment
than what she's had to do with
pretty much two weeks of being told all these like
she must go online and see how people respond she
fired her pr team oh yeah this trial no she
has to know she knows i mean she's because
she's been living with this longer than the truck
it's constantly reported on how many signatures
are on that remove amber heard from aquaman 2 yeah
petition which has been up since before this trial
well before yeah yeah so like that's why it's it's
like she like the the best case i can give her is
if she is telling the truth she's having a hard
time because she feels she has to put up a certain
type of one-woman show in order to try to sell
them like keep looking directly at the jury like
really you know cheat your body with them yeah
yeah tell them and it does seem like over the top
but but i can't even as someone who doubts the the
validity of some of a lot of what she talks about
it i can't say i'm like i've met
people who are really dramatic
and that to me contributes to this
she's from she's an actress in l.a
crying out loud that's the first thought i had the
first thought i had was i feel like i'm watching
an actor do a monologue and acting class and
okay it was like it felt like acting class time
yeah yeah i don't know see that's the thing
is i can see it and and i i don't have a good
uh like conclusion based on it i'm like i can see
what you're talking about and there are elements
of the way that she you know it's like you watch
johnny depp on the stand and he's very much just
like super chill and just answering questions
occasionally laughing whereas yeah she is
there to prove a point which to be fair
i mean she is there to prove a point
uh yeah it really makes me wonder because
if it is just that her personality is
that way uh and you know she's up here giving
a testimony then of course that's going to be
consistent with how her personality is and if
that's all true then she must be sharing her her
side of the she must believe what she's saying i
guess is what i imagine if again we can trust that
account of her psychology because then you hear
these tapes and you can hear yeah some instances
of like yeah it sounds like she's in pretty
much peril in this recording or whatever um
yeah again it's one of those things where i feel
like in certain ways they're probably both telling
what they think is true and i i can't i don't know
it feels to me like there are two teams the johnny
depp's team is people who love johnny depp and i
feel like amber heard's team is mostly people who
care about assault victims not people who really
care that much about amber heard and so that's
what makes me i think there's i think giant has a
lot in his camp more i like that i think there's
a giant just the jdep super fans and i and i
also think there are people who uh who do suffer
domestic violence and believe him they're even i
believed amber heard at first you know yeah and
i don't know i mean i don't not believe a hundred
percent of the things she said just because again
looking at all this evidence and looking at the
situation clearly there is abuse between two
people happening and i think what they are trying
to do is figure out who the primary abuser was
and uh that's that's just a nasty nasty task uh
figuring out if johnny depp defended himself or
attacked her and to if if i think i don't think
there's a way to truly know no you can't no you
can't no you can't it's it's it's hard it's like
you choose you choose to you have to choose to
you choose what you believe yeah that's
why i always say this is what i believe
you know like i i'm choosing what i believe
here yeah because not one of them goes
i mean depending on the subject but like
yeah i haven't heard johnny depp in
a private conversation ever say like
i hit you because i was defending myself although
there was that thing with like the toes and like
having to get away so accidentally hurt her
yeah yeah thing yeah yeah and the door on her
feet yeah so there's that and then the biggest
discrediter of amber heard for me is that is
the recording are those recordings where she's
basically saying like yeah i start these fights
for this reason and i didn't hit you i hit you
this way and your response is invalid because of
this well then you hear all that and you hear her
testify and then the test and the testimony seems
a little bizarre yeah then you go i don't know if
i could believe you yeah that's the most telltale
and the stickiest detail that like that's the
thing that keeps me coming back to at least her
side of this and going something doesn't feel
quite on the level here and i can't really tell
well the bottle incident i mean look it up i
don't want to like fully recount it um it it does
what a lot of i've heard some people say like
logically this is what i mean they don't say
the words logically but that's what everyone's
implying is logically if johnny depp did do
that bottle incident wouldn't she want to go to
the hospital and get that checked out she could
have suffered injuries from that there could be an
infection there's a lot of things yeah logically
at the same time that a big problem is many people
especially like in you know marital situations
even non-marital they don't go to the hospital
they don't get checked out uh they don't report
it like there's a there's it's very very common so
i so i'm like yeah of course logically you should
but i'm not gonna be here being
like here's why i don't believe
that didn't happen it it'd be because of
the logic of not getting that checked out
logic is always a bad place to turn and
assault cases i think we've had too many
accounts now not to realize that like yeah
you don't necessarily behave logically when
these things happen and especially something
is intimate and and yes i don't know like
you got to feel embarrassed and violated in in a
myriad of ways after a situation like that that
probably wouldn't make a lot of people actually
want to go seek out like let me go find people
in public and deal with this you know yeah i mean
even when like johnny depp got his finger cut off
like he lied and said that he did it in i mean
according to his testimony key member's name
out of it that yeah you know it's and so it's
like if amber heard it's going there and like
here's what happened you know there's that fear
there's a lot of reasons i could justify as to
why she didn't go too well and that did happen
yeah and i mean i feel like if there's also a
position to be like okay i got a piece of my
finger sliced off but we're gonna protect her
still i feel like that's also indicative of a
situation in which those kinds of things might
be a little more common than you like if
that was a first time offense and that was
the crossing of a line i don't know if that
would be the response it could be but it it
feels to me more indicative of a toxic scenario
where things like this actually do kind of happen
and maybe this was an extreme case but you know
things like this do happen with us yeah no they
it's just such a heavy accusation yes and
regardless and if that is not the truth
in a lot of ways that doesn't matter for a lot of
people because a lot of people already believe it
you know if it's not true i mean if it's not
like it's that is among the most vile things
you can do is fabricate a scenario like that
she just i keep going back to how she testifies
i keep going back to that that's
part of it like because the thing is
we've seen like countless people testify this
for yeah and she's a very specific type of
person when she's testifying and a lot of it seems
to be looking at the jury for approval on a lot of
her behaviors there's this one moment that people
are saying she posed for a photo like with the
tissue and usually when i hear that i'm like that
sounds like a reach then when i watch it i'm like
god damn it really does seem as i am likely to
believe that she is you you see her like put the
tissue on look up hold still click and then go you
hear the click of the camera yeah and then go away
and then i'm like and sure enough that's the photo
yes of course yeah i mean if she especially if she
replaced her pr team i mean you know she's
aware of things like that and and part of me
the sympathetic side of me goes well that's smart
because you know that that's one of the assets
that you especially need to play into but at
the same time it is a contrivance you know it is
a bit disingenuous if that is in fact the case
yeah uh rings like i don't i don't know where to
land on that it doesn't ring at least like a
genuine like i'm just wiping a tear like that
bottle story's so horrific and for someone
to say like where's the evidence i'm like
i i i would say get out of here with that
it's really hard to if that's a private moment
it's really hard to just be like
well why don't you take photos
like you can't just say that to someone you know
you you can't when you're nice position you take
photos and the thing is that subject that story
in particular it's like again if that is the truth
then bravery for sharing that and doing
this if that is not the truth it is such
an evil manipulative thing to do to people who are
watching this she knows people are watching this
terrible to do to join dad you know and pin and
terrible new giant debt but there are there are
like i said there are individuals who have had
instances like that and worse and consistently
in domestic partnerships that would
then that that makes them immediately
like you would just believe that person like there
are people who would just instantly believe that
there are people that who have been in those
situations who don't believe her though for that
case and not just because they're johnny depp
superfans because they'll be like well here's
a lot of things of why this doesn't sound real
and it's and a lot of it comes down to the way
she paints it yeah yeah i mean you got
to help yourself just as much as any of
the other witnesses have you know on your
side have to help you it's like she kind of
talks like the issue i have and i
know it sounds like i'm making a joke
the issue i had when i was trying to read
tarantino's once upon a time in hollywood book
okay that would flip between telling
like okay sometimes this book sounds like
a novel most of the time he's writing the the the
non-dialogue scenes like action lines in a script
yeah you know yeah yeah yeah like it it
doesn't seem like she's really i don't
really like reliving a memory yeah it it sounds
made it sound it's like oh sometimes it reads to
me that you remember breaking bad when walter
white made that fake confession yes about hank
in the last season yeah sometimes it reads
like that but a worse performance than that
you know um
so yeah it's so hard to tell
it's so hard to tell because yeah
i can't sometimes things just come out awkward and
stiff or some people aren't very good at acting
yeah obviously we're trying to be a little bit
fairer here i think compared to 99 of the
discourse we've entertained both sides pretty well
because i don't know ultimately
justice for somebody just
just as uh like so hard here let
me i'll i'll end it with this
the trial is not done there's more to come
there's counter i'm blanking on so many words
for a discussion video like counter depositions
no no no no cross-examination yeah yeah it's
cross-examination uh there's cross-examination
there's there's there's more to come out you know
and this was the first time i've ever really
listened like let's listen to amber heard talk
and i went in with an open mind and as much
as i i'd like i just remember hearing her
cry and be like let me pull up my phone and
look at this yeah yeah yeah i don't know man
yeah it's tough it's tough there are
certain things that you should just
never do like there's a certain percentage of this
where i'm just like it's just two people who are
really abusive towards each other although there
are certain allegations where i'm just like that's
something no person should ever do and be allowed
to just maintain their happy life from you know if
if some of these you know nastier allegations are
true so i mean for me personally i don't feel like
i'll ever know the answer and i'm probably gonna
remember this whenever i think of either of them
from now on um but yeah it's gonna keep unfolding
and then there's gonna be another trial in uh the
fall so we'll have this to relive again get ready
for christmas with amber heard and johnny depp
yeah yeah i don't know i like i i can't discredit
her entirely because i think there's a zealousness
that people have in doing so and i think it's
a bit dangerous for the overall discourse
for that to happen but i think there are a lot of
legitimate there's a lot of legitimate skepticism
i think about how she's approaching this and
leading into this trial and even before these
trials were things she didn't have always the best
reputation on a personal level um not to say that
your ex-wife and stuff yeah and uh you know that
is what it is the past as we said for johnny depp
the past is the past you know now is what we're
talking about but at the same time you know
i don't want to fully i can't but she had good
conscience she had just she was in the transition
process of leaving that relationship and then
went right into this one yeah no it's never that
is rarely a recipe for a good relationship so i'm
saying if she was that person in that relationship
then i'm like i don't think she like changed yeah
yeah not not just getting into this relationship
now i'm a whole new person yeah totally and i mean
you can see too things where people who start out
really all about each other as they describe like
oh man it's obsession yeah and and like you said
passion can often be driven by a certain kind of
of dysfunction and a certain kind of pain and i
feel like more than anything else we've learned
here it's just that these two people harmonized
pain and trauma and got a lot more of it in the
process even when she's testifying and maybe this
is just a smart choice on johnny depp's end he
does not watch her he does not look up at her
that was the thing is i was watching for
hours to to be that committed to like
hurting your neck and back because you just
refused to look up at your abuser yeah that
it's interesting to see again it's it's where
she just like looks at him coldly stuff like
this like weird mannequin look that she's watching
yeah you watch it during all of his testimonies
and for the most part she's very still and then
occasionally we'll get that verge of tears face
and then kind of oscillate before the trial
seems like she's been trying to cry and just
can't quite get there yeah i can't i can't tell
if it's somebody who's too exhausted to cry
or somebody who's really trying to cry when
you're making that face for hours and hours on
end i'm talking about when she's testifying
you'd think a real tear would a couple
couple streams might come out a little bit you
would imagine after a couple of weeks at this
yeah the emotional toll has to win yeah
that would have to be a little bit of like
i'm finally talking you know but then again i
mean the other thing that it might just be so
bottled up and repressed they've already tested
she's already had to testify this stuff once and
and live for months with just this whole
situation i'm sure absorbing her life so again
the problem for me is i can never get to
a thing where i'm like a hundred percent
now you know i understand at this current
moment i have a really hard time believing her
i do like just and i i'm mainly going off of yeah
i already had an opinion but then watching and nor
am i saying johnny depp's a [__] saint you know
but so he yeah like the image that he's painted
of her sounds like a weird choice
to say a choice of words to say
but it's but it sounds like a fair portrayal
of what he believes to be his abuser
she is describing something else entirely
the appearance definitely does feel that way so
that's what just makes me even more doubtful like
you're you're trying too hard but i don't know
maybe like for all i know she might whip something
out next week and i'm like holy [__] i take back
everything you know yeah it's not over until it's
over and it's probably not over then either
you know they they have to they this is this
is a sales pitch to the jury it is 100 you you
can't and and and one of the biggest things is
you got to plant the seed what you got to
do in a court trial is you plant the seed to
so that way when the people start coming up
defending the individual you're doubting it but
you have to really bring it home in the end yeah
you know yeah yeah you've got to put stamp on it
it's like there's more audio there's more [__]
there's so much more [__] yeah they could that
could they could have just like let me just dump
all this in the beginning but they didn't do that
you gotta spread it out you know you gotta build
the narrator you gotta build to the finale mm-hmm
you know and that's the impression
you're gonna be left with yes you
gotta convince 10 people of your side
yeah how many people are in a jury
you know a baker's dozen yeah i
mean what it where i am right now
is basically that and like clearly there was
abuse between two people and what i'm dubious
about or what i'm curious as to the
legitimacy of is the most extreme claims
of like direct abuse that i don't think could
have come out of some kind of blackout scenario
and unprovoked you know like those truly
dastardly allegations are the ones i'm
most curious about because i think again i think
this well establishes that they abused each other
through their relationship for whatever
understandable reason or not you know i feel like
that is true so i i don't really fall on the side
of like no just johnny [__] it yeah you know
like like it is a very human like to i it gets
people very charged for very legitimate reasons
and if i remove myself from the emotion and and
you know the experiences of people i know it is
a fascinating just experiment to peer in on
in terms of you know psych psychology and and
sociology well it's not like it's because the
reason why it's so one-sided i mean a i'm always
the thing i'm constantly bitching about is how
there seems to be a lack of gray with any subject
in this world gotta choose one and once you've
chosen you can never unchoose that yeah yeah
you can never act on new information
you will be judged from your
previous belief yeah you know yeah like i i it's
like you know you like this seems to be such a
hypocrisy with the idea of growth and change
um like you should and then when you do no
yeah you're in hell so you can never make
the right decision yeah so it's it's a pain
in the it's a pain in the ass um so uh well
that's my god it's happening again there was
there was a point there's something about oh where
are we just saying yeah john this one gets cut
out during all the evidence uh just the shadow
of a doubt stuff the sort of like the biggest
the biggest most damning
allegations uh something about them
well yeah just to me the truth of the matter right
now is that at very least it seems evident they
both were abusive toward each other for
various reasons and i just don't know if
the most vile and the most sort of clearly
victim and aggressor ones are the truth
see i can believe a scenario this is where you
piss off the world i i can believe a scenario
of johnny depp being so inebriated that
he doesn't remember doing it i absolutely
believe that's possible i've seen it happen
in life he's a bit of a rock and roll star
you know yeah even though in his testimony he
is saying like he doesn't ever get to that point
where he doesn't you know and like those photos
were those photos i don't think are condemning
damning evidence i i don't believe they are
condemning him like he's passed out do you see the
way that ice cream hit his leg he's got a crazy
lifestyle he's it works weird hours you know yeah
i've fallen asleep in this room yeah this very
room i've fallen asleep in just like at a computer
and i'm like oh god i just dozed off all editing
yeah 100 you know and you're a drunk and an addict
for doing so yeah um yeah but i i i i don't
think uh i i really don't believe though that
he's i could be wrong he doesn't believe like
a malicious guy he doesn't seem like the kind
of guy who would get emotional to the point he
would strike you right it doesn't seem as though
the only way i could believe he would like might
have hit it was if he was that inebriated and it
wasn't a fight either that or or in a situation
where there were already hands being thrown or
something yeah or something yeah where he was
already been provoked you know like i don't know
like it's weird and and this is a we we brought
you to end this but yeah that's that's what i
mean it's a never-ending talk well yeah and why
there's channels who have committed their lives
because there's so much to the human nuance and
the weird gray areas and and two the fact that
we're zooming in and focusing in on little details
way more than you do under normal circumstances
and those can cause those details to unfold or
to suggest things that you might not have seen
and also too there's the bias of what are you
looking for because you might just find what
you're looking for rather than what is actually
happening you know like there's there's so much
to it and it's really fascinating because while
it's created this very polar division it's like
to me a very unpolarized situation when you really
dig deep into it and yeah i feel like yeah like
something could have happened where if
he was blacked out sure which is its own
thing that should have consequences that should
be dealt with it's not saying it did that's
not we're not here saying he did do that i'm
saying like that's the scenario i could believe
that's what they see if they prove that
you know that's what seemed most likely
yeah i mean it seems like it would have had
to have happened at some point but i don't uh
i don't know i don't rely on this yeah
this is why i don't do we don't do like
daily videos we don't want to make the channel
about this no but it's something that you know
is a part of entertainment
media now is this is why
you know that thing that drew barry when you see
that thing when did you very much had a friggin
apologize for talking with anthony anderson about
the trial oh no she was talking she was pretty
much the the language and the description of her
experience was talking about it in a way that's
like entertainment oh and which rub people
the wrong way yeah because it shouldn't be
it's become that it's a circus but it shouldn't be
entertainment it shouldn't be but i think too for
millions of people it certainly is this
is yeah for millions of people this is the
best tmz episode you could you could go on tick
tock and you'll see a ton of people just being
like getting my popcorn ready you know like
that michael jackson gift has to be everywhere
it's like this is a this is a this is a source of
this has become a main source of entertainment and
like like i said i could i could i i could be here
every day without john because i have like i keep
up to date with this and i really listen i don't
just listen to clips you know like i'm really
paying attention oh yeah whenever whenever i go to
examine the trial i'm like where's that seven hour
live stream yeah let me put this on five speed
yeah you can see my red mark on where i'm at
you know i'm catching up too like because
we share the same account so yeah so you're
watching on law and crime are you on crime network
okay maybe i'll switch to them i've been on nbc
maybe their coverage is what pops up for me yeah
that's what i use um yeah like it's this is it's a
really fascinating thing and people are eating it
up like an like a form of entertainment and even
people got to be honest about that even before
you know people who are taking this serious like
it's really hard for me to come on here and just
make jokes about this well and like just do like
funny meme reactions and [__] like that because
i think to be able to do that you have to have a
conclusion you have to feel like you know or a lot
of people feel like they know or have a distance
from it yeah you know like these people don't
really matter to me haha like i want to make jokes
about ezra miller if i was seeing videos of him
throwing a chair at a woman and damaging her face
yeah you know and so now it's making me i mean i
don't think i made jokes in that video but i'm not
making light of that scenario no no um that's
the i don't know i'm trying to use a different
example didn't make jokes about will smith that
was stupid though that's not the same that's it's
the difference this is a different thing yeah
it's not the same thing yeah yeah yeah you know
there's there's a ladder yeah and the slapping
is is rung one it's not not the biblical times
if every sin is equal yeah yeah yeah absolutely it
must be judged um but i mean it's it's fascinating
and engrossing but it more just makes me sad
than than like oh fun you know it's not enough
i don't think this is am i amused and entertained
by it of course i am i think a lot of us are oh
yeah but at the same time i wouldn't i wouldn't
necessarily use the words at times charles [__]
boring as [__] it's like a drama that happens to
be funny on occasion because life is occasionally
funny it's like yeah johnny depp will make
a remark that's kind of a zinger and it's
funny but yeah at the same time the situation at
hand is very it's if you get invested you know
it's like you know it's engrossing you know you
people who watch like true crime documentaries who
want to be like this is not entertaining yeah i
don't like that okay let's look over your netflix
account and see if you like murders murders
are less messed up than personal relationships
all right like which are arguably might be true
and then the one thing we didn't touch on is
the subject too of like men who suffer domestic
violence yeah which is which is a thing that is
like there are men who laugh at this subject like
she hit you so what don't be a [__] you know
i mean and johnny depp coming from the family of
with an abusive a mother who apparently abused his
father and is triggering him yeah like like it's
common it's much more of an accepted standard for
a woman to slap a guy like he was out of line he
messed up he cheated or something like whatever
it is uh you know he was being stupid that's
that's the realm i don't i would be curious to
hear people who know a lot more than me unpack
that one because part of me is like well if we
do live in this weird in in this equal world
you know it's like you shouldn't nobody should
hit anybody and you know i i still kind of have
that belief from how i you know just the kind of
default settings of growing up of like yeah man
doesn't hit woman it's just not something you do
as bad as immediate line cross but then i think of
these situations where it's just like two people
fighting each other yeah and like it's it's that
that's why i guess it comes down to the primary
aggressor question because after a certain point
part of me if you isolate the worst allegations
and certain other things it is just sort of
like this is just two toxic people fighting
each other and so if hands were thrown on both
sides it seems like it it cancels out not that
it cancels the actions taken and the harm done by
those but it cancels out like the innocence factor
to me where it's just like you're kind of both on
that level together and there's yeah that view of
like well it's immediately [__] up if it's a man
hitting a woman which again i i still have that in
my dna but at the same time it makes me curious
about like well if you just have two people who
are fighting back and forth you know and you don't
know yet who the primary aggressor is like what
what is that situation exactly like if you know
if a woman is laying into a guy and hitting him a
bunch you know and he hits back what are the rules
of that like i'm actually curious to hear some
good theory and thought on that because i haven't
really had to think much about that you know
i mean i feel like my train of thought is like
if she's punching him a bunch or something you
gotta like just push her away or or you block or
push her away whatever you know like use your foot
to like kick her away yeah but if you're but if
you're talking about a situation in which a man
like clock them in the face like like get to get
away from me yeah you know if you are a man and
i guess to clarify if you are a man in an abusive
situation for example and you are being physically
harmed in either repeatedly or in a specific
incident what are the rules of that like what are
you you know what is messed up to you know what
what kind of retaliation or defensive measure is
messed up and i think there's a pretty clear line
you can find of when defense transfers when you go
too far you know and then it's like whoa slow down
you know like now you're you're flying off the
handle but you know in an abusive situation where
the male is the victim yeah what what are the full
ethics of that missile strike is too far yes yes
yes you don't launch a missile on your partner
but yeah you know because right there
you've lost a fight because there's
that immediate thing of like if a man hits
a woman that's kind of an immediate like a
violent assault like there's something very ugly
that naturally comes to that that i don't you know
take any issue with the response thereof
but yeah if it's you know if if that type
of abuse is happening and it's physical
abuse towards a man what are the rules
you know when are when are you not uh [__]
up in yeah defending physically i guess
we'll keep a lookout for
our dr strange spoiler talk
after this delightful brief sojourn into the real
world a lot of our audience is listening to this
trial a lot of everybody's listening to this trial
see what else our audience is listening to oh
hey they're watching this obscure documentary
yeah let's cover that now yeah let's watch some
let's do it all horrific true crime
series react to the dirty details
this video is finally done or audio depending on
what we decide we did it see you guys aquaman two
you